you know there was a there was a there
was a gold rush moment in of the
internet do you remember it when you say
free you mean uncensored yeah yeah
that's not gonna happen again it's just
the technology is too powerful
[Music]
nobody would allow that uh what do you
think about what Elon is doing with
Twitter
What specifically
yeah that's interesting so the way that
I see it is him taking over the saying
making it open source so people are not
open source but uh transparent so
everybody can see what the algorithm is
and
um there's no mystery about who's
getting blocked or why
and that part of it I like that part of
it I like but I think
um I've not I never met Elon I actually
did Bill Marshall with him today but we
didn't get a chance to talk so I don't
know what he's like I've never met him
and I'm just saying this is an outside
Observer and I actually think he's a
very important figure in the culture and
what he's attempting to do in terms of
the survival of humanity actually really
important I disagree with him about
certain things
but you have to be honest and recognize
that Twitter is a benevolent
dictatorship which is much better than
the the oligarchy we had before it is
better but
I see that there is you know any
dictatorship is benevolent as long as
it's benevolent right
um so you know for example
uh Twitter I think is in a bit of a
standoff with sub stack at the moment uh
which if someone who writes on sub stack
I find it a little bit frustrating
what's the standoff uh the standoff is
that sub stack came up with a thing
called sub stack notes which I think the
people at Twitter believe is an attempt
to compete with Twitter
which I don't think it is given that sub
stack I think have you know like 35
million subscriptions versus whatever
Twitter has you know they're not
comparable but
um there's been some things that
happened on that front that make me you
know
make me think that you know I really
wish this dictatorship remained
benevolent for as long as possible is he
throttling sub stack people or something
like if you're trying to link out to it
or
I don't have access to the actual data
to be able to say accurately there was a
period of time it was quite short when
if you posted a sub stack link on
Twitter you would actually if you
clicked it it would be it would take you
to a page of saying this link is unsafe
interesting and if you tweeted a link to
to sub stack you couldn't like or
retweet it you could only quote tweet it
so it was direct suppression right this
happened for a very short period of time
uh and then we are in the position where
we are now where some people say
suppression is going on quietly and some
people say it's not um yeah
interesting well if he makes a code
available people real fast point out
whether that's really happening or not
yeah but that's interesting okay so free
internet was a moment going away
um it becomes a very interesting
question getting back to do we want
freedom of speech how far in uh kiss and
land we're gonna go what we're gonna I'm
so grateful I'm not Elon I cannot tell
you just the pressure or what that
decision that specific one decision is
like where's that line nobody not nobody
knows because once you go from anyone's
allowed to express an opinion which I
genuinely believe like you and I sitting
here without the cameras on if you want
to be racist I may not stick around but
I believe you have a right to say that
right hmm
what about when that is recorded on
camera and it goes out to millions of
people what if I say as David Ike this
conspiracy guy in the UK said at the
beginning of the pandemic that kovid is
caused by 5G and then the next day
people go out and burn down 5G masts
right you know that I was appalled I
found a decision to that's not probably
not even a word I found the decision to
ban Trump from Twitter abhorrent yeah
but I can also if I'm being
intellectually honest I opposed it
completely and I said it at the time I
can find it in my mind a situation in
which a leader of a democratic country
in my opinion should be banned from the
Public Square really yeah give me an
example
well it's obvious if they're inciting
large-scale Mass violence for example
they're saying you know what we need to
do is go out and shoot these people
right now I don't think Putin tweets but
would you do them if you did because
there is a guy oh God I follow him I
forget his name on the Russian side
because I was like oh my God like he's
tweeting what he really thinks about the
West this is crazy yes he drinks a lot
and I was like whoa like this guy's just
not pulling any punches like these
idiots and all this I was like wow like
okay this is why I'm saying I'm grateful
not to be in the position where I have
to make these decisions because I think
at the end of the day because there's no
right answer there's no right answer
we're all fighting over where that line
is and my argument is that line has been
pushed way in against free speech I
think that's elon's point and that's why
he's taken over Twitter and that's why
he's rolling that line back but
inevitably there will always be a point
where you go okay that's far enough I
think yeah because the technology is too
powerful now the impact of words is so
cat is not but can be so catastrophic
but then again I can see counter against
my own argument I mean think about you
know
what about the Civil War in America a
bunch of people saying you know we must
end slavery and if people want to fight
us over that we've got to go out and
fight what if that happened today what
if people went out and said you know we
gotta fight whatever
and that means we need to pick up our
weapons and go to the streets
do you interfere with that as the owner
of Twitter
man so right can I can I throw some
really bad ideas that I man I'm thinking
through this I've not had to to
articulate this stuff to myself or
anybody else but so here's where I come
down on this um